et on va prendre direction la direction
de la géorgie à présent nous attend le
correspondant de rfi régis genté bonjour
régis est ce que l'on pouvait se douter
avec l'exemple géorgien de 2008 que
vladimir poutine voudrait manger un peu
plus de terrain j'ai envie de dire et
envahir l'ukraine
oui absolument s'il ya bien un pays dans
le monde qui n'a pas été surpris et qui
depuis des mois et sinon des années
prédit qu' effectivement ce scénario
allait se dérouler c'est bien la géorgie
effectivement je me souviens après au
lendemain de la guerre de 2008 la guerre
russo géorgienne qui est aussi avait
commencé dans un territoire séparatiste
l'ossétie du sud les dirigeants
géorgiens me disait tu verras la
prochaine cible ce sera l'ukraine est à
l'époque moi même je dois le reconnaître
j'étais assez incrédule donc c'est
vraiment un scénario que qu'on a imaginé
on sait à quoi servent les comparatifs
qui sont factices ça veut dire qu'il ya
pas de dissension dans un pays mais de
là à en faire un conflit c'est une autre
histoire sont des conflits factices sont
des objets fabriqués pour ensuite
permettre à la russie est bien de
défendre ses intérêts géopolitiques
telle qu'elle est telle qu'elle est en
temps après ce que j'observe ce qu'on
observe des derniers jours ces dernières
24 heures même je dirais montre que le
scénario est en train d'aller au delà de
ce qu'il a pu être en 2008 en géorgie
jean yves le drian le chef de la
diplomatie française dit s'inquiéter
pour la géorgie et aussi pour la
moldavie avec la transnistrie est-ce qu'
il peut y avoir de l'inquiétude
concernant la géorgie où vous trouver
mais aussi la moldavie donc
absolument c'est la même histoire en
réalité j'ai l'impression que le kof
2008 a servi en quelque sorte à la
russie comme un exemple comme un
avertissement en dix ans si vous taxez
des panneaux demande sécuritaire les
garanties de sécurité etc c'est à dire
aussi un contrôle sur ce qu'on appelle
l'étranger proche en russie eh bien nous
allons faire la guerre à l'époque en
géorgie par exemple les chars s'étaient
approchés à 30 kilomètres d'ici pour
menacer la souveraineté peut-être même y
est telle une tentative de faire tomber
le président saca juillet à l'époque là
on voit qu'on est dans l'étape du dessus
en ukraine il ya probablement une
volonté et une bataille de qu'est-ce qui
est qui et lancez donc on est on est sur
un stade supplémentaire mais on est dans
la même logique avec d'ailleurs à
l'arrière on s'en doute le scénario tel
que vu
faussement mais par vladimir poutine
d'une revanche sur ce qui s'est passé au
kosovo et en serbie en 1999 et il est en
train d'appliquer ce schéma en quelque
sorte à son propre compte ou huit ans à
sa façon ce qu'a pu ce qu'ils croient
avoir été l'action de l'otan à l'époque
merci beaucoup régis jantes et pour
votre analyse depuis tbilissi en géorgie